hi i'm priyanka vergaria and this is ai
simplified where
we will take the journey from data sets
all the way to deployed machine learning
models
no matter which service you offer today
it is crucial to use the data you have
to make predictions so you can improve
your apps and the user experience
but most teams have varying levels of
machine learning expertise ranging from
novice
all the way to experts to accelerate ai
innovation
you need a platform that can help you
build expertise
for those novice users and provide a
seamless and flexible environment
for those experts this is where
vertex ai comes in it provides tools for
every step of the machine learning
workflow
across different model types for varying
levels of machine learning expertise
before we take a look at vertex ai
though let's understand the typical
machine learning workflow after defining
your prediction task the first thing you
do
is ingest the data analyze it and then
transform it then you create and train
the model
evaluate that model for efficiency and
optimization
and then deploy it to make predictions
now with vertex ai you get a simplified
machine learning workflow
in one central place ingestion
analysis and transforming is really all
about data preparation
and you do that using managed data sets
within vertex ai you have tools to
create the data set by importing your
data
using the console or just the api you
can also
label and annotate the data right from
within the console
for model training you have two options
automl
or custom with varying machine learning
expertise on the team
for some use cases such as images
or videos text
files and tabular data
automl works great with automl you don't
need to write any of the model
code vertex ai will take care of finding
the best model
for that task and for other use cases
where you would like
more control over your model's
architecture
use custom models now custom models are
great for
frameworks and architectures and code
that you want to write yourself
so this works great for tensorflow or
pytorch code
once that model is trained you have the
ability to
assess that model optimize it and even
understand the signals behind your
model's predictions
and you do that with explainable ai
and explainable ai lets you dive deeper
into your model and understand which
factors are playing a role in defining
what that model is predicting once
you're happy with the model
you deploy it to an endpoint to serve it
for online predictions using the api
or the console now this deployment
includes
all the physical resources and the
scalable hardware
that's needed to scale that model
for lower latency and online predictions
you can of course use the undeployed
model for batch predictions
once the model is deployed you can get
the predictions
using either the command line interface
or
the console ui or the sdk
and the apis at this point you might be
wondering
how this looks in the console and where
to find it
so let me give you a little tour of the
dashboard
in the console when we click on vertex
ai we land on the dashboard
where you can see the recent data sets
recent models
and get predictions on the left
you have all the steps that are involved
in the machine learning workflow
all the way from data sets to
predictions
in the data sets you can create your
data sets depending on the type of data
and your prediction task
supported data types include image
tabular
text or videos if your prediction task
doesn't fall into one of these use cases
don't worry
you can still use vertex ai for your
custom model training
and prediction once you have created a
data set you can see it listed in the
dataset list
in the notebook section of the console
you can create your customized
notebook instances with the type of
environment
and gpus you want
the training tab you can see and create
your training jobs
the beauty is that you can have one data
set
but you can train it in different ways
with auto ml you can train a
high quality model with minimal effort
automl edge for models that are
optimized for edge devices
and with the custom training option you
can train models built
with any framework we are pre-built or
custom containers
pre-built containers are available for
supported
frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
scikit-learn
and xgboost you provide your code as a
python package
the custom containers option allows you
to train
models built with any framework or
language
by putting your training application
code in a docker container
push it to container registry and run
training on vertex
you can accelerate the training with
gpus and
also apply hyperparameter tuning
in the models tab you can see all the
models you have created
here you can also import models trained
outside of google cloud to serve it
for online and batch predictions in
order to use a model
you create an endpoint which brings us
to our next step
creating an endpoint is how you serve
your models for online predictions
each model can have multiple endpoints
enter the compute resources
so your endpoint can auto scale the
resources based on your traffic
you can even split traffic across
endpoints and send
model logs to cloud logging once the
model
is live we can make predictions in the
ui
or through the sdk in the batch
predictions tab
you can make predictions on the batch of
data from cloud storage
this was a pretty high level overview
where we saw that vertex ai provides the
tools to support your entire machine
learning workflow
from data management all the way to
predictions
in the next episodes we will dive much
deeper into
all of these steps and build end-to-end
machine learning workflow
in the meantime let's continue our
discussion in the comments below
i'm excited to hear all about your
machine learning use case and workflow